Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
¿Sabías que cada vez que los
músicos tocan sus instrumentos
se desatan fuegos artificiales
en sus cerebros?
Por fuera, puede que
parezcan calmos y concentrados,
que leen la música y ejecutan los movimientos
precisos y practicados requeridos.
Pero dentro de sus cerebros
hay una fiesta.
¿Cómo lo sabemos?
Bueno, en las últimas décadas,
los neurocientíficos
han dado pasos enormes
en la comprensión del funcionamiento
del cerebro, estudiándolo en tiempo real
con aparatos de IRMf y PET.
Se conecta a las personas
a estas máquinas,
y al leer o resolver
problemas matemáticos
se activan las correspondientes
partes del cerebro
donde puede observarse actividad.
Cuando los investigadores pusieron
a los pacientes a escuchar música
vieron fuegos artificiales.
Se iluminaron múltiples zonas
del cerebro a la vez,
conforme procesaban el sonido,
lo separaban para entender los elementos
como la melodía y el ritmo,
y luego los unificaban nuevamente
en una experiencia musical.
Nuestros cerebros hacen todo esto
en una fracción de segundo
entre que escuchamos la música y empezamos
a seguir el ritmo con los pies.
Pero cuando los científicos
pasaron de observar los cerebros
de quienes escuchaban música
a quienes la tocaban
los pequeños fuegos artificiales
se convirtieron en un jubileo.
Resulta que si bien escuchar música
hace participar al cerebro
en algunas actividades muy interesantes,
tocar música equivale para el cerebro
a una actividad física completa.
Los neurocientíficos vieron encenderse
múltiples zonas del cerebro
que procesan diferente
información en simultáneo
en secuencias intrincadas, interrelacionadas,
asombrosamente rápidas.
Pero ¿qué aspecto de la música
enciende al cerebro?
La investigación es
todavía muy prematura,
pero los neurocientíficos
tienen cierta idea.
Tocar un instrumento musical activa
prácticamente todo el cerebro a la vez,
en especial las cortezas visuales,
auditivas, y motrices.
Y como con cualquier
otro ejercicio,
la práctica disciplinada
y estructurada de la música
fortalece las funciones cerebrales,
permitiéndonos aplicar esa fuerza
a otras actividades.
La diferencia más obvia entre
escuchar música y tocarla
es que tocar música requiere
motricidad fina,
que se controla desde ambos
hemisferios del cerebro.
También combina la precisión
lingüística y matemática,
para la que el hemisferio izquierdo
está más desarrollado,
con el contenido nuevo y creativo en
lo que sobresale el hemisferio derecho.
Por estas razones, se ha
encontrado que tocar música
aumenta el volumen y la actividad
en el cuerpo calloso del cerebro,
el puente entre los dos hemisferios,
permitiendo que los mensajes lleguen
más rápido a través de vías más diversas.
Esto podría permitirle
a los músicos resolver problemas
de manera más eficaz y creativa,
en contextos académicos y sociales.
Dado que hacer música implica
también elaborar y comprender
su mensaje y contenido emocional,
los músicos a menudo tienen niveles
más altos de funciones ejecutivas,
una categoría de tareas interrelacionadas
que abarca planificación, formulación
de estrategias, y atención al detalle
y requiere análisis simultáneo de los
aspectos cognitivos y emocionales.
Esta habilidad también tiene un impacto
en el funcionamiento de la memoria.
De hecho, los músicos presentan
funciones realzadas de memoria:
crean, almacenan y recuperan recuerdos
mucho más rápida y eficientemente.
Hay estudios que encontraron que los músicos
parecen usar sus cerebros altamente conectados
para ponerle a cada recuerdo varias etiquetas:
una etiqueta conceptual, una emocional,
una de audio, una de contexto,
como un buen motor de búsqueda de Internet.
¿Cómo sabemos que esos beneficios
son distintivos de la música
y no de, digamos,
los deportes o la pintura?
¿Podría ser que las personas
que se dedican a la música
ya fuesen más inteligentes de por sí?
Los neurocientíficos han explorado
estos temas, pero hasta ahora han hallado
que los aspectos artísticos y estéticos
de aprender a tocar un instrumento musical
difieren de cualquier otra actividad estudiada,
incluyendo otras artes.
Y varios estudios aleatorizados
de los participantes,
que mostraron los mismos niveles
de la función cognitiva
y el procesamiento neural en el inicio,
hallaron que quienes fueron expuestos
a un período de aprendizaje musical
presentaban mejoras en múltiples zonas
del cerebro, en comparación con los otros.
Esta investigación reciente sobre los
beneficios mentales de tocar música
nos ha permitido comprender mejor
la función mental,
revelando los ritmos internos
y la interacción compleja
que componen la orquesta increíble
de nuestro cerebro.